let us now go through another example
which will be a little more challenging
we're going to revisit an old problem we
have a coin that has an unknown bias
theta and we have a prior distribution
on this theta we fix some positive
integer and we flip a coin and times
that has this unknown bias and we record
the number of heads on the basis of the
number of heads that have been observed
we wish to estimate the bias theta of
the coin to make things more concrete
we're going to assume a prior
distribution on theta that is uniform on
the unit interval now this is a problem
that we have considered before we have
calculated the expected value of theta
given X and we did find that the
expected value takes this particular
form now notice that this is a linear
function of X and if it turns out that
the least mean square system ATAR is a
linear function of X then we're
guaranteed since this is the best that
this is also the best within the class
of linear estimators so we immediately
have the conclusion that the linear list
min squares estimator is this particular
function of X so there's not much left
to do on the other hand just for
practice let us derive this answer
directly from the formulas that we have
for the linear list min squares
estimator and see whether we're going to
get the same answer so we want to use
this formula and in order to apply this
formula all that we have to do is to
calculate these expected values this
variance and this covariance so now let
us move on to this particular
calculational exercise let us start by
writing down what we know about the
random variables involved in this
problem about theta we know that it is
uniform and so that it has a mean of 1/2
and the variance of 1 over 12 about X
what we know is the following if you fix
the bias of the coin the
and the number of heads you are going to
obtain in n flips has a binomial
distribution with parameters and then
theta but of course theta itself is a
random variable so for this reason this
is a conditional distribution but within
the conditional universe we know the
mean and the variance of a binomial and
they are as follows the mean of a
binomial is n times the bias of the coin
but because we're talking about the
conditional universe this is a
conditional expectation and it's a
random variable because it's affected by
the value of the random variable theta
and similarly for the variance it's the
usual formula for the variance of a
binomial except that now the bias itself
is a random variable so now let us
continue with the calculation of the
quantities that we need for the formula
for our estimator let's start with the
expected value of x since we know the
conditional expectation of X we can use
the law of iterated expectations the
unconditional expectation is the
expected value of the conditional
expectation which is n times theta and
since the mean of theta is 1/2 we obtain
n over 2
let us now continue with the calculation
of the variance there are different ways
that we can calculate it one could be
the law of total variance but we will
take the alternative approach which is
to use the general formula for the
variance that the variance is equal to
the expected value of the square of a
random variable minus the square of the
expected value we know the expected
value of x so all that's left is to
calculate the expected value of x
squared how are we going to calculate it
well we know the conditional
distribution of X so it should be easy
to calculate the conditional expectation
of x squared in the conditional universe
and then use the law of iterated
expectations to obtain the unconditional
expectation so now we need to calculate
this conditional expectation here how do
we do it the expected value of a square
of a random variable is always equal to
the variance of that random variable
plus the square of the expected value
we're going to use this property but
we're going to use it in the conditional
universe so in the conditional universe
this is going to be equal to the
variance in the conditional universe
which is n times theta times 1 minus
theta plus the square of the expected
value of x but the expected value in the
conditional universe which is this
quantity n times theta so we obtained
another term and squared theta squared
so now we can go back to our previous
calculation and write here the expected
value of this expression which is n
times theta and then we have some theta
squared terms one is N squared the other
is a minus end so we obtain plus N
squared minus n theta squared the
expected value of n times theta is n
times the expected value of theta which
is 1/2 so we obtain a factor of n over 2
but then we have this additional term
here we need the expected value of theta
squared what is it well since we know
the mean and the variance of theta we
can calculate the expected value of
theta squared it is equal to the
variance plus the square of the mean and
this evaluates to one-third
so from here we're going to obtain plus
N squared minus n divided by three and
you can rewrite this term in a different
way by collecting first the N terms and
over two minus n over three this gives
us n over six and then there's the N
squared term which is N squared over
three now that we found the expected
value of x squared we can go back to
this calculation we have n over six plus
N squared over three minus the square of
the expected value of x which is this
expression here so we obtain minus N
squared over four 1/3 minus 1/4 that
makes 112 so we obtain n over six plus n
squared over 12 or another way of
writing this is n times n plus 2 over 12
and this completes the calculation of
the variance of X the last quantity
that's left for us to calculate is the
covariance of theta with X we're going
to calculate it using the alternative
formula for the covariance which is the
expectation of the product minus the
product of the expectations we have the
expectations but we do not have the
expectation of the product so we need to
calculate it once more it's going to be
the same trick we're going to condition
on theta and then use the law of
iterated expectations so the law of
iterated expectations when you condition
on theta takes this form and to continue
here we need to find this conditional
expectation in the inside
this conditional expectation what is it
if I give you theta then you know theta
it is becoming now a constant there's
nothing random to it so it can be pulled
outside the expectation and we obtain
theta times the conditional expectation
of X we know what the conditional
expectation of X is it's n times theta
so from here we obtain overall term n
times theta squared so now we can go
back here we have the expected value and
the term in the inside we just found it
it's n times theta squared and since the
expected value of theta squared is 1/3
from here we obtain n over 3 and now we
can go back finally to the calculation
of the covariance it's going to be n
over 3 minus the expected value of theta
which is 1/2 times the expected value of
x which is n over 2 so it's minus n over
4 and this evaluates to n over 12 so we
have succeeded in calculating all the
quantities that are needed in the
formula for the linear lists mean
squares estimator we can now take those
values that we have just found and
substitute them in this formula and
after a little bit of algebra and moving
terms around everything simplifies to
this expression just to verify that this
makes sense what is the coefficient next
to X its the covariance divided by the
variance and over 12 divided by this
expression this n cancels that n with 12
cancels that 12 were left with an N plus
2 in the denominator and indeed the
coefficient that multiplies X is the
term n plus 2 in the denominator and you
can similarly verify that the constant
term as well is the correct one so of
course this answer is what we had found
in
the past to be the optimal the least
mean squares estimator of X as we
discussed earlier when this is linear in
X it has to be the same as the linear
least mean squares estimator so this
answer is not a surprise but it was an
interesting and perhaps useful exercise
to go through the details of this
calculation to see what it takes to
figure out the different terms in this
formula